I wasn't sad when scream queens went
away only because I trust Ryan and you
know like I think the final quote he
said was I told the stories I wanted to
tell with these characters so it is an
entertainer an artist I would never want
to stay on to something that you know if
we've moved on from it so I definitely
was like I'm so glad I got to work on
that show and hopefully you know look at
the opportunity to work with Ryan again
but the most thing I miss other girls
you know there's a lot of friendships
that were made on the show so to not see
them as often it's definitely like oh
dang it you know what I mean but I know
I will see them again Oh sort of
conclude you guys hang out well I have
all the way I've been all the way in
Berlin so I haven't been able to see
everybody as much as I wanted to and
then actually I just moved from LA so I
usually come to LA now for work you know
and things like that but I love my girls
and I'm actually hoping to see Billy
while I'm here how is she doing she's
doing good you know she's strong as heck
you know what I'm saying she's always
been that way when I actually did season
1 in New Orleans we were both so like
alone like oh my gosh when we can't win
we go home and visit family and friends
and we spent a lot of time together and
you know built a bond off of that so I
know that she can take pretty much
anything and you know her mom and you
know grandmother's better please know
what am i singing yes
well music I'm always doing I'm always
doing music actually just put out like a
mini mixtape with my girlfriend Raya
it's called Kiana Nicole it's available
now on streaming and pretty much once I
get back home to the land I'm going to
finish up some more of my music I don't
want to say too much but I'm going to be
releasing some more soon what else you
want to do I mean what oh my gosh what
do you see I mean I know that's a that's
I know what you're saying yes what else
you wanna do well you know like I said
well that's the gag I know started this
is one of my shows as well as the show I
have called the vibe on my digital
channel youtube.com slash keke palmer
and for me producing new content geared
towards my generation is what I want and
a lot of times we don't always see it on
television and if we do it's not often
told from the generation and I think
that digitally I have so much control
creatively to really you know offer that
voice not just my own perspective but
other people's perspectives so to get an
opportunity where I can be in the
position to not only greenlight the
shows that I'm interested
and digitally but other people's is
something that I'm very very big on and
it goes the same thing with music I
think for me the end game is to always
be able to give what I've been given you
know I've had a lot of mentorship
throughout the industry and I've
experienced a lot of great things so for
me I want to be able to give a lot of
that back to questions on that set there
are a lot of veteran actresses yes
rylann station yeah Catalan station do
you ask them for advice or do they you
know is that even in the yes you're the
young yeah they are the kind of young
Berlin station they're not the kind of
people that's like let me tell you
something girl but I'm always watching
okay you don't say like I would you know
be a animal under the sea I'd be
Spongebob honey because I'm soaking
everything in so I'm more so watching
them and learning from watching them
than they are aware that I am you know
what I mean they're not they don't know
that I'm watching but I am and who would
be your dream culture in life my dream
co-stars in life Wow all that is hard
okay my dream co-stars in life oh my
gosh I'm trying to think I was you
really laid it on me oh my goodness okay
I think like I said I would always love
it's my dream like to be able to work
with Will Smith so to do a project with
him we're both like just kicking butt
and doing from the bad act like that I
would love same thing with Wesley Snipes
blade I think those are amazing like you
know trilogies and so to do something
with him would be amazing I love that
action and ease more serious so that's a
different aspect um and who else who
else who else there's so many different
people that are amazing to work with
that I would love to to act with um who
would be your celebrity crush my
celebrity crush hello
always Michael Ealy I love Michael Ealy
I love my couch and say I worked with
Michael Ealy when I was 9 years old on
barbershop 2 and literally I will never
forget he was the nicest I'm telling you
I've experienced a lot of good things
industry when I was a kid my clearly was
so sweet to me and then I did my dance
team reunion and worked with Boris
Kodjoe and he was really sweet to me so
I office I've had a great blast